a bird's eye view of this palm oil
plantation would normally reveal a vast
field of green
instead it looks like a muddy river
slaves of malaysia including johor state
are covered in flood waters after the
heavy rains that began last weekend
some villages like pucho village are
still cut off
reachable only by boat people here say
they barely had time to get away from
the rising waters
we managed to take our important
documents and some clothes
not much else the water rose so quickly
we had to get up fast they've also lost
their only supply of clean water after
flood waters contaminated the well
across the country tens of thousands of
people have been evacuated
living in schools and community centers
[Music]
i thank god we're all alive me my family
my grandkids
it doesn't matter if we lose our stuff
they're just things
what's important is that we're all alive
with flood waters receding so slowly
and rain forecast to continue many will
be unable to return home for days
it's not just homes that have been
damaged but livelihoods
behind me is a vegetable farm it's
completely submerged
the crops have been destroyed and
farmers say they don't know when they
can begin replanting
the floods caused by the northeast
monsoon
which usually runs from november to
february are an
annual occurrence although the severity
varies from year to year
florence louis al jazeera clung district
johor malaysia